faites le tour devant eux pour les
éloigner de l'eau, ça va, pouvez-vous faire
le tour devant eux pour les
éloigner de l'eau ou peut-être pas non,
peut-être qu'ils vont juste
s'assurer qu'ils ne les courent pas ouais, d'accord
il en manque un et trois d'entre
eux, il y en a deux désolé, je regarde
du mauvais
côté, où est le troisième, ouais, ouais, ok, je l'ai mis
dans le
plan, peut-être, euh, laissons-les en quelque sorte,
oui, nous les laissons, nous
allons les mettre à l'eau, n'est-ce pas ?
aller à l'
eau et si on ne
bouge pas ok ils sont près de l'eau maintenant
ok ils n'y vont pas ils n'y vont pas
ils n'y vont pas
ok juste euh qu'allons-nous faire
ici attendons juste ici
attendons juste ici, nous sommes très très
proches, où est le troisième, non, il
n'y a qu'ils se sont arrêtés, ils se sont arrêtés, ok,
pouvons-nous descendre plus bas, ils ne l'obtiendront peut-être pas, alors euh ouais,
vous devrez descendre,
ok, ne vous inquiétez pas, restez où nous sommes.
beaucoup de euh ok l'arrêt
parfait nous attendrons ici, ils s'arrêtent
ok et voulons-nous risquer le euh le
doubleur euh faisons-les marcher
maintenant ouais laissons-
les marcher et ensuite ils seront
probablement plutôt cool  en bas
[Musique]
euh nous euh merde, ils vont dans l'
eau, c'est bon, nous pouvons les faire nager,
ils ne le feront pas, euh,
pouvons-nous les avoir
ah, ils nagent, c'est le
plan, nous allons par-dessus
eux mais ils vont changer  direction maintenant,
je ne
sais pas quand ils sont dans l'eau, ils
ne peuvent pas,
oh allons-nous
les perdre, je ne peux pas les voir, je les vois
nager, pouvons-nous dépasser les 500
pieds au-dessus d'
eux, c'est parti  qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire tu veux
aller grimper grimper à 500
pieds, monter à 500 pieds et revenir sur
eux ok LIF
P tu l'as où est
est
oh merde où sont-
ils nous allons les dépasser juste
ici en dessous  tu es à droite oui à
droite non non ils sont à ma
gauche je ne sais pas où ils sont là-bas j'ai j'ai
ok il
leur reste deux heures euh oh c'est drôle je
les ai où pourrais-tu tourner l'
hélicoptère à
180°
s'il te plaît nous  j'ai, nous avons un m et deux
bébés euh je le tire à 17h00
maintenant 17h00 à notre droite tu
devrais maintenant ouais 5h00 M bébés à 17h00 nous
passons là-bas, ils sont tellement
mieux ouais  ok, peux-tu voir le sillage dans
l'
eau oh je les vois ok 1h00 maintenant 1h00
maintenant 1h00 ouais euh à
100 m de la rive allons tout
droit tout droit j'ai
compris ils sont très loin ouais probablement pas  Je ne
vais pas
plus haut, mais à quelle hauteur sommes-nous
maintenant, à quel point
ok, ralentis, ralentis la vitesse,
ralentis la vitesse, ralentis la vitesse,
ralentissons la vitesse.  passé
[Musique]
ok, peux-tu les voir ouais ok fais
comme
ça ouais
ok pouvons-nous juste perdre la vitesse de l'air juste
survoler euh quel genre d'image veux-tu
ici ouais juste c'est bien c'est bien ouais oh
oui ça sort large  angle et regarde-les les voir
alors nous commençons un plan, survolez ici ouais,
ok, nous avons un plan, voici cet angle
qui est avec cet angle, je m'organise
comme ça,
ok,
puis je chante
juste
là,
ils dépassent un peu
de glace
maintenant
donc il doit y avoir eu euh deux ours
restés à l'intérieur, puis la maman et le bébé sont
partis séparément ouais c'est un joli ouais,
ils se rapprochent du rivage, de la
glace, maintenant ouais, qu'en est-il d'attendre
ici alors on les laisse continuer  le rivage
ouais, amène-les simplement au rivage,
alors nous ferions mieux de nous arrêter, je pense qu'ils
recommenceront à courir dès qu'ils arriveront
au rivage, ouais, peux-tu avoir plus,
plus de matériel sur l'eau avec la
piscine, ok, arrête juste d'enregistrer à partir de
oui  on roule ouais ça
roule un peu comme rester ici et attendre qu'ils
sortent de l'eau ça
pourrait être sympa
oui Concentre-toi bien
FOC
ok est-ce qu'ils se rapprochent du rivage
je suppose qu'ils
ouais
ils vont parallèlement  au oh
non, ils entrent, ils entrent
dans cette petite région de la baie,
nous ferions mieux de les laisser quand ils arriveront,
ça va être un si beau
coup
ouais, il, je pense que nous ferions mieux de les laisser
ouais et un peu comme d  Zoom ou ouais laisse-les
sortir ouais comme ça ooh
magnifique ok on ferait mieux d'aller prendre la photo
comme ça toujours toujours en train de
sortir
ouais ok ok
allons-y super
seulement ok devrais-je m'arrêter non continuer d'
arrêter arrêter ok si nous allons juste à droite
dans le cercle, tourne légèrement à
droite, tourne à droite
lentement, c'est
peut-être trop
large, je peux encore voir en bas de la
photo mais bon, c'est probablement bien ouais, on y
va, on y va, on y va bien